I love Donald Trump and no then he went
Donald Trump killed Donald Trump I love
Donald Trump but no more dropped by the
drop boxes are just so bad no more drop
boxes Dickinson hologic and cephe
cephahide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney real Beauty had
to give the American people their voice
back by building something called truth
truth essential
against Kate's law and it and even four
[Music]
amnestys you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've endorsed
JP right JD Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations than Jesse
James Billy the good some of the world's
greatest cricket players from suchin
tendulkeron Colleen as the great
religious teacher Swami Vive come on
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
the United States thank you very much he
was awarded the broad star and the
combat infant trip and badge for his
service we have to keep our country gay
people but it's not I mean for some
reason it's just not great anymore if
you care about law and auto look Law and
Order in normal times roughly 40 percent
of fresh vegetables at about 40 percent
China nambia's health system is
increasingly self-sufficient this is not
about virtue cycling and signing and the
great General and President
Ulysses S Grant he's done he's really
come back a long way over the last 10
years hasn't he
appreciate it very much Tim Apple when
they gaze upon your semites your
seminites towering sequoias they deliver
they swept and swept in you know that
sweeping it was Swift and it was
sweeping like nobody's
ever seen anything happen units of
plasma for plasma donate plasmid into
failing New York Times by
Anonymous really an anonymous
coward I may ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading woman's business who teaches
you should ever be allowed to teach
transgender to our children well enough
to rent up himself
no
nobody has to have parental consent and
we will totally oppose the bind
Administration against this
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements on Jewish
you've heard them and you know them well
[Music]
elements of bathrooms
what on Earth is going on with Trump
toilets
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
[Music]
ten times
the United States thank you very much
elements of bathrooms well welcome
everybody it is campaign 2024 and it is
really getting going tonight we are
expecting that Ron DeSantis as soon as a
little bit of uh I guess you could call
it Rhonda Sanders as a paperwork problem
where right now the law in Florida is
that you have to resign the governorship
in order to run for president and
Republicans in the state legislature are
trying to change that so that Ron
DeSantis will be free to announce but in
the meantime it is Trump versus Nikki
Haley uh and Vivek ramaswamy that's the
Republican primary right now and moments
from now mere moments from now mere
Earthly moments from now we are going to
hear from the failed former president
who again wants to be president in Iowa
delivering a speech on education now I
can only imagine that if Trump is
talking about education he will be
talking about so-called parents rights
and when Trump talks about so-called
parents rights he talks about no one
should be allowed to teach transgender
and we will bend men so I think we will
almost certainly hear from Trump about
teaching transgender tonight this speech
is scheduled for just a few minutes from
now I'm so glad that you're joining me
we're going to look at some of what's
been going on behind the scenes there in
Davenport Iowa and I expect it to be an
extraordinarily unhinged evening
unhinged evening
um okay what is happening with the
facial hair nothing really I mean you
know it's just it's it's there uh
uh yeah
there's really there's really nothing to
talk about as far as the facial hair
goes Jacob says sir where did the mango
song Go via Super Chat just didn't play
it today it's it's still there I mean
listen it's let me see where it is here
mangoes
I could play it at any time but I just
didn't play it today and uh and that's
it okay let's look at a little bit of
the behind the scenes happening at this
Trump event but before I do that I do
want to just thank a few people who have
already uh supported today's stream pink
and blonde that crazy guy Lisa Lee
weather boxer Billy Carpenter and
mortimax all uh via twitch supporting
today's stream which I love
um a YouTube viewer named Obama promp
says David sir I'm coming to you with
tears in my eyes to say thank you for
all you do well thank you very much
Obama Obama I appreciate that let's look
at a little bit of what's been happening
behind the scenes right side
broadcasting caught an explosive story
outside the venue uh wherein someone was
accused of having cut the line which is
a big deal at these Trump events look at
this what's your name Brian right side
broadcasting thank you likes Trump so
much he cut in line in front of 800
people
with no courtesy to anybody else in line
I did not know a wrap around the corner
I saw you guys but you never moved you
know now though dude now you know we
inform you let's be a negotiator so
Trump's a negotiator
what are the senior citizens yeah I
really can't stand people who just do
this this happens all the time you know
when I go to
um uh the grocery store it will often
happen that
there is how can I describe this
oh sometimes like there's a line you
know in cities if by the way if you go
to the Union Square Whole Foods it's a
mess in there okay so this this is like
basically every every time you go but at
a lot of busy grocery stores
um there will be the registers and then
the line would block the passage so
people stand back to leave a gap is what
I'm saying clear do people know what I
mean like there might be an interruption
to the line because if you didn't
interrupt the line you would just block
everybody trying to get through with
cards who were shopping and not in line
can you more or less visualize that
people understand okay you make a
passage Gap thank you exactly common
courtesy and it will happen very often
that someone will come up with a cart
they either don't see or pretend not to
see the fact that the line continues and
they'll just go right up
I don't allow this I go right up to then
I say excuse me we've all been waiting
in line the line is over there and 95 of
the time people go oh oh oh oh oh I'm
sorry I didn't know and then they go and
get in the back of the line
one out of 20 right five percent of the
time they just don't care they go oh uh
I'm here now
what what do you mean what do you mean
you're here now what exactly does that
mean and
um whenever I go over and I tell them
you've got to go to the back of the line
all these big strong guys come up to me
crying and they salute and they say sir
that was unbelievable and uh I can't
believe that you took care of the
neo-marxism here and you're certainly
not teaching transgender and then they
insist on paying for my groceries which
is crazy when it happens uh but anyway
yeah that happens and it's just like
dude go go to the back of the line
you've been informed now
all about him no no I remember the show
People's Court remember People's Court
all right so as you can see everything
going really really well at this event
there was another interesting moment
where a woman at the Trump rally said
she wouldn't vote for wrong Des Sanctus
because he's funded by George Soros did
anybody talking about any other person
for president other than Donald J Trump
any other name no no no
yeah there you go de Sanctus has Soros
money so that's not going to be a a good
candidate for that young lady big thank
you to
uh
uh hold on big thank you to John stickle
John stickle just signed up via twitch
and his new member number seven today
and even more powerfully Martin Fillion
and Jason sickmeyer have each just
gifted memberships on my website folks
if you want a free website membership I
have them available you need only put in
your info at davidpackman.com free
membership okay if you want a free one
go to davidpackman.com free membership
because two of them were just donated
and that's an absolutely fantastic thing
super chat's coming in Andrew says do
you think Trump will talk about sending
astronauts on Nars I certainly hope so
I certainly hope so and gwj says David
have you been keeping up with the
banking sector news regarding Silicon
Valley Bank silvergate First Republic
Bank do you think more is coming I do
not believe that we are on the precipice
of a major series of Bank collapses
um period that that's you know anytime
we're predicting stuff it's like what
the hell do we know but that's my
opinion apostate Alexei asks via Super
Chat David do you know why they refer to
him as Donald J Trump does that add some
extra oomph or what honestly I don't
know I really don't know
let me tell you guys about something
very very serious that's going on
about a year ago I was approached by a
documentary film company
and they asked me to use a clip of this
segment okay
on a documentary The segment is called
debunked
Flight MH370 Rothschild patent
conspiracy theory now
when you see this as the title of I'm
going to test the audience okay
when you see this as the title of a
video
do you assume I believe the conspiracy
theory or do you assume I'm debunking it
please let me know in the chat when you
see the video title debunked
okay do you think I'm spreading
or debunking
spreading or debunking which do you
think is most likely when this is the
subject the title
I'm debunking that's exactly right
in this video I debunk
look at that hair something very wrong
happening on that day I debunk this okay
they paid me 500 bucks for the license
fee which is fine but I made a mistake I
didn't say to them
the context must be that I am debunking
and so they included the clip in a
montage
of conspiracy theories making it look
like I am spreading
another conspiracy an outrageous
Insurance scan some of these people who
showed up outside my office who would
chase me down in a car park it was quite
scary I remember spraining an ankle once
trying to escape one of these people who
really just wanted to bring their Theory
to me four days after the flight
disappeared there was a patent issued
for a new semiconductor technology so
they're making it seem like I'm
spreading one of these conspiracy
theories that then this clueless guy
goes and shares on the internet this is
literally the opposite of what I was
doing now
I'm not blaming anyone but myself
I am the one who should have insisted on
a different sort of contract but
I'm gonna do everything I can
to get Gloria Allred and Mark garagos
and Marco Mara who defended George
Zimmerman and get them all to sue
oh people are saying it's not your fault
David they obviously were deceptive yeah
well listen
this is why today's coupon code is
indict as we stand by for Trump yes the
coupon code indict is a reference to the
fact that we are damn well beyond when
we should be indicting Donald Trump but
the coupon code indict also refers to
the documentary people by the way this
thing is number one on Netflix it's
number one on Netflix and it makes it
seem like I'm spreading conspiracy
um we're gonna try to sue them to high
heaven okay so uh what I ask of you
today in all seriousness we're kind of
joking but I'm also kind of serious it
would be really great if you signed up
and got a membership on my website we're
doing a whole bunch of new stuff
including we've got a Spanish channel
that we're paying for dubbing on all of
this stuff is expensive I would really
love for you to sign up at
joinpakman.com if you have cable you're
giving Fox News four dollars a month a
lot of people don't know that if you
have cable the deal that Fox News
negotiated is they're getting four bucks
a month
from you okay
use the coupon code indict you'll pay
like two bucks a month and you'll get a
membership to my website and the bonus
show and all of these great things okay
so I do appreciate people doing that uh
the code is in diet and I want to say
thank you to Martin Fillion who is the
latest to subscribe on the website a
couple things on the table if we get to
100 website members tonight I will open
phone lines after Trump's speech and if
we get to 250 on tomorrow's show I will
shave half my mustache and the opposite
half of the goatee and do a show like
that and I know some people are like
David don't do that but I will do it I
will do it which will be incredible and
also thank you over on Twitch to Tiny
sir Jen for gifting five subscriptions
let me see if I can keep up here that
puts us at 15 and then gustavionde as
well as Alice maravillas have all signed
up and that puts us at 17. Super chats
are dumping in uh we will we finally see
Trump care revealed I don't think you're
going to hear that tonight no
I saw it the documentary was almost
entirely conspiracy theories oh God yeah
I would I would be super interested to
sue and say that it damaged my
reputation so if we have any uh lawyers
in the audience I think that that would
be a really interesting case to take up
and I invite you to uh you know join me
in my
and my lawsuit or whatever the case may
be a couple other things here oh yeah we
were just looking at a couple of other
elements here from this Trump event let
me see if I can get to the other one uh
oh a guy was asked what he most misses
about Trump
um biggest things you miss about
President Trump
the frankness the honesty
he misses Trump's honesty God this is
this is why you know you really can't
convince these people
um
here's another one let's see let's see
what are you looking forward to to
either sing and hear it from the
president today
yeah in terms of Education what would
you like to see him change or improve or
suggest um enforce God and patriotism
yeah very very sick people folks
extraordinarily sick people I want to
say a huge thank you to Martin Fillion
and Josh Breton each of whom just signed
up on my website joinpakman.com I
absolutely love it okay people are
asking am I serious about suing the
documentary company
so here's the deal if a lawyer came to
me and said David you actually do have a
case even though you gave them a license
to use the clip period rather than a
license that requires context I would
absolutely sue them if a lawyer came to
me and said Sir with tears in my eyes
you don't have a case then I wouldn't do
it I'm not looking to just sue for the
sake of suing but it would be a
fascinating story to do it I think it
would be really interesting as an
element for the show as well so anyway
that's sort of my thought right now
thanks to covert Ninja for the twitch
Prime subscription you're number 20
today we are moments away from hearing
from the failed former president Donald
Trump I can only assume because this is
a speech about
education that he will talk about
teaching transgender
that's uh that's a big thing for Trump
uh I want to say a big thank you to
Martin Fillion who just gifted another
subscription which are available at
davidpackman.com free membership uh
let's look as if we have time at another
clip or two here is a guy explaining
what he learned from Tucker Carlson
about the Trump riots well let's just
keep let's keep that up
the people that really did the damage
[Music]
folks he learned from Tucker that it was
antifa
antifa oh God we're so screwed as a
country God it was antifa and Tifa did
the riots that's what he learned from
Tucker Carlson dear God punch me in the
face we are so screwed as a country
it was antifa God
all right here's Trump
he's already hinging forward at the
waist thanks to pow owl as well as lizer
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at 23. also
um
oh no that's it that's sad
oh sorry thanks to Gary Reich for
signing up at joinpakman.com you're
number 24 today we are going to listen
and I am sure learn about education
policy I would expect this to go about
four hours probably it'll be Castro like
Trump just likes to keep going and going
and going
[Applause]
[Music]
here's a suggestion if you need a good
lawyer I hear Jenna Ellis and Sydney
Powell are available what folks what's
going on right now is Trump came out too
early and so the song just keeps playing
and he has to awkwardly hinge at the
waist like that
[Music]
it's like he came out way too early for
this to not be awkward
[Music]
yeah thanks to sleeveless inmo Dragon
for the twitch Prime subscription you're
number 25 remember we'll open phone
lines at the end of the stream if we get
to a hundred if we survive to then
foreign
it's just Trump came out way way too
early thanks to Sam Dean for gifting
five subscriptions on Twitch I
appreciate that sir
[Applause]
Trump seems they actually use uh you
know
my physics class in high school had
Trump already been president Trump's
stance should have been used to learn
about mechanical physics Trump he seems
cantilevered interestingly enough it
would be uh everybody who is in the
business of building buildings should
actually observe the way Trump stands
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
super strong
oh thank you very much
thank you very much and thank you great
Governor that was beautiful that was
beautiful energy he's got that energy
I wish we could have gotten everybody
and you have to see outside there's so
many people want to get in you're so
lucky you're so lucky we're gonna have a
good time so the audio is unsynced I
will refresh once but if that doesn't
fix it it's probably the feed if I come
back to Davenport all the time it's been
really good to us so that's not working
let's try the rumble feed but I just
want to thank all of the great people
are proud to be the home of the first in
the nation caucuses
and we kept it that way Kim didn't we we
kept it that way as president I fought
hard and one two perfect I was first in
the nation status and the Republican
Party a lot of people called me about it
including your governor and I said we're
doing it that's where it's going to be
it's where it's going to be for a long
time as long as I'm around I'm telling
you it's going to be
the Democrats did it a little bit
differently didn't they they they chose
a different order I want to thank Kevin
Reynolds also because he's been a friend
of my sons and a friend of mine they
like hunting and they're the only two
you know a long while ago we had a
situation where Kevin and my son Don
went out hunting with a certain
gentleman who we love a certain Governor
previous governor and they had a very
cold weather the only two that didn't
show up for three days back everyone
came back in about 15 minutes it was too
cold we're done and Kevin you remember
that Kevin they said what happened to
those two those two could take the
weather there was no problem they came
back that they said what's the problem
but I just want to thank you very much
Kevin great job great job you've done
Donna says hello
I also want to congratulate and thank
lieutenant governor Adam Greg Adam thank
you very much
[Music]
former acting attorney general Matt
Whitaker a friend of ours for a long
time horrible guy
he's been a great gentleman
and your former congressman who I
endorsed very very strongly we had a
good run with Rod Blum thank you Rod
Plum thank you Rod good job it is a
state representative Brooke Bowden
thanks Brooke
Scott County Sheriff of the most
beautiful family Tim Lane thank you Tim
Iowa Republican party chair Jeff Kaufman
[Music]
Scott County GOP chair Juanita McNulty
that's a nice day
one of the first elected officials to
endorse me I love this guy he was so
early
he addressed before before I was even
running he said you know that guy would
be good
those are the guys we really like uh
state Senator Brad John
oh we love that guy
thank you I also want to thank my Iowa
senior advisor representative Bobby
Kaufman and many of his colleagues Bobby
is so good
the way this is going I would expect it
to run five hours
feeling very good I want to tell you you
know you can tell by the crowds outside
you can tell by the crowds but his
colleagues in the Iowa House and Senate
who are here and they've all endorsed me
and I really appreciate that including
state senators
Jeff reichmann
Charlie McClintock
state representatives Craig Johnson
and owes Munson and I love that what did
he say Mark Cisneros
Steve Bradley
Derek Wolfe
Heather horror
Brad Sherman Heather horror Cindy
Golding
[Music]
and by the way you know we're going to
do a little bit later if we have a
little time left which I think we will
we'll take a few questions does anybody
want to ask oh my God
unlike Biden you can ask me whatever the
hell you watch
I have to tell you random people asking
Trump questions this I have to see he
was reading the answer of a teleprompter
I said I've never they've never done
that for me
Trump's using a prompter right now you
want uh we'll finish up and we'll have a
little fun okay you can't say anything
you want you can give me the worst
toughest most horrible question who
cares right who the hell cares
for seven years our Maga movement the
greatest in political history there's
never been anything like this has been
taking on all of the evil and Sinister
forces trying to destroy America's
future you know that you know it better
than most we stand up to the globalists
we stand up to the marxists Marxist
remember he said we will never have
socialism that train left socialism a
long time ago never even stopped at that
station we stand up to the Crooked
Democrat prosecutors all over the
country there's there's no Marxism in
the U.S happens to be Democrat let's
call him into a grand jury they have
never nobody's ever weaponized like this
group of people they're Maniacs we stand
up to the Rhinos Communists and the
anti-energy extremists
that weird thing going on with the audio
it's something there where like the
crowd is like not Audible and then it
pops up it's very weird
[Music]
[Applause]
we put workers first we put Farmers
first and above all we put America first
we put America
in our four incredible years and they
were incredible years we achieved more
for Iowa than any president in American
history is not even a contest and in
particular the farmers they know better
than anybody working hand in hand with
Iowa's leaders I was the most pro-farmer
president that has ever been in the
White House by far I was rated that by
everybody didn't he ruin the fight I
appreciate the farmers I know how smart
they are how good they are and how hard
they were nobody in history did more for
Farmers of our country the great Farmers
than I did
to protect Family Farms I virtually
eliminated the unfair estate tax or
death tax who do you know remember that
was a bad glitch trying to get this past
I don't know if I can get it
but if I do if you love your children
you can leave your farm to your kids if
you don't love it you don't have to
worry about tax no tax
they call it a death tax that's a not a
nice word but you know very appropriate
if you don't like your kids that much or
if you don't like them at all which
happens on occasion don't leave them a
thing Trump knows about that don't worry
about it there's anybody in here not
like their children
oh be careful
someone cheered we got to be careful
with that
the problem is the fake news media is
going to report that as fact you know
that you're going to have a lot of
explaining to do
he loves his boy he loves his family we
also gave a giant tax cut to Family
Farms that operate his pass-through
entity is a big thing for you Farmers
which constitute more than 90 percent of
all agricultural production in the
United States so we got the pass-through
done nobody thought it could be done I
repealed Barack Hussein Obama is
ridiculous Waters of the United States
it sounds so nice Kim it sounds so nice
Waters of the United States I said I'm
going to get killed when I repeal this
one because the only thing good about it
was the title Waters of the United
States
and I repealed it a federal power grip
with over every ditch and every puddle
on private lands I make it sound like it
was a lake you couldn't use your
property what a lunatic you're taking
your property away I'll never forget
when I did it I had a group of farmers
and Builders home builders standing
behind me about 50 of them crying when I
did it half of them these are men and in
some cases about five women they never
cried in their life before super strong
yeah maybe in their mother's arms but
they're not dryers half of the people
were crying I gave them back their
rights I gave them back their property I
mean it was an incredible
heroic actions quite frankly
and our Department of Agriculture cut
seven old regulations for every one new
regulation saving farmers and taxpayers
including the types of regulations that
led to the train derailment as well as
the recent bank collapse disaster worst
trade deal
ever made and replaced it with some
with something very much with the usmca
Mexico and Canada best trade deal there
are almost no differences between those
two trade deals shake the deal I see
they're up there we want to renegotiate
it's not working so well
we want everybody to be happy but it's
better that way than the other way for
many many for decades we had to live
with NAFTA what a disaster it was but
the usmca we're very proud of that
everyone said that's another thing
couldn't be done we did a lot
and my personal assistance to prime
minister Trudeau
The usmca Pride open Canada's Dairy
poultry and egg walkers for American
Producers they were shutting us out you
have no idea Trump Pride opened poultry
China like no Administration has ever
done before
and I brought in hundreds of billions of
dollars of tax and tariffs and all sorts
of Revenue pouring into our treasury
from China when no other president had
ever gotten literally 10 cents nothing
they came in and they took our country
by storm and we stopped it and we made
one of the greatest trade deals ever
we were mistreated by China and our
farmers were mistreated
more than anybody else and I took a list
as to what amount that bad treatment was
and I went to our really he did a great
job Sonny Perdue he went to Abdul right
Sonny let me ask you a question I want
you to figure out over the next couple
of days or sooner how much money
did China rip off our farmers in this
country you have to tell me he got back
to me and he gave me it on a yearly
count he said sir but the total was 28
billion dollars
and I told Johnny you have to pay it and
you know what they paid it they paid it
many of the people in this order that
never happened I took it out of the
tariffs
oh that I charged China we had a lot of
money left over I can tell you that we
had remember he still doesn't understand
how tariffs work the tariffs are paid by
American companies we took a lot of
them saved the steel unders who received
a lot of Industries
we handed checks to the farmers for 28
billion dollars did anybody get a check
in this room for the farmers because you
gotta be yes that's good nobody got him
not as many as I would have thought you
all got checks but maybe you're not in
that business but we're all with the
farmers and they got 28 billion dollars
nobody saw that one coming that was one
that they said this is incredible but it
also made a deal with China and the deal
with China was a phenomenal one by
people who wanted 15 billion dollars in
agricultural purchase I said you have to
buy
and otherwise we're not going to do
business with you and other things other
than the forums
and I said what's the number 15 billion
I said did I hear you correctly I
thought they said 50 billion right they
said 15 billion I said I think I heard
50 billion just an electric speaker the
crowd is riveted they're still doing
so well today
no they are totally
totally possible and the reason they're
not totally living enough to say no
respect for the Biden Administration but
still more money that's why the farmers
are continuing to do well but China and
the usmca were just the beginning of our
fight for the American Farmer I also got
Japan to slash or eliminate tariffs on
over 90 percent of U.S food and
agricultural exports people knew that
what a difference it made I dealt with
the great prime minister
prime minister ABI he was my friend of
Japan
and that one who unfortunately as you
know was assassinated by a Madman but
what a great man he was and his people
loved him but he was very fair to us and
we opened it up because we were being
treated very unfairly by Japan as we are
by almost everybody I have to tell you I
can't think of anybody Trump is the
biggest victim and the U.S are the
biggest victim we do have
34 trillion dollars in debt so I don't
know if you call that survival you know
eventually that comes back to haunt you
right right but we didn't make any good
deals we had no good deals so we made a
lot of them great and some of them
phenomenal the European union agreed to
nearly triple its beef Imports and
opened it markets the markets to
American soybeans at a level that nobody
thought was going to happen I also won
our Farmers gigantic concessions from
South Korea Argentina Brazil
Tunisia Ecuador Morocco and many many
more
I was working very hard on Europe and
that was going to be a deal that was
done because they don't treat us very
well Europe believe it or not you know
it sounds anybody know what he's talking
about
come from Europe sounds very nice but
they treat us very bad on trade very
badly on trade
and even if you look at the war if you
look at what's going on we're spending
we're about 150 billion and they're at
about 25 billion I would say that's not
right you know somebody's here to tell
them all you have to do is say listen
you're delinquent you gotta up it you
gotta up it it's not fair not fair to
our country it's not fair but we had a
an election it feels almost like it's a
completely empty room good at all you've
seen a lot of the reasons for it's a
disgrace we've got more votes than any
sitting president in history by a lot by
millions we got 75 million votes more
that's what they report
they say the other guy got 80 I don't
think so and I don't think so he did one
hell of a job from his basement
yeah like I said on the pbd podcast if
you're Trump and you lost to a guy who
ran against you from the basement I
wouldn't be talking about that I'd be
embarrassed to boost Farm exports by
more than 60 billion dollars supporting
millions and millions of American jobs
and right here in this room and right
here in Iowa
and that's what happens when you have a
president who stands up for America and
who puts America First it could be done
it can be done
I remember France
who I like a lot but France uh they were
going to put a tax on a lot of our
business almost all businesses dealing
in France and I said that's okay if they
do that and my people came back to me
smart people sir they're going to put a
tax on and
and uh you know what I'm talking about
and there's a good man as a friend back
road and I said uh listen here's what we
have to do
if you want to do this because my people
came back after like two weeks they
couldn't get anything they got nothing
Kim you have people that are better than
that I'll bet
but they couldn't get anything and they
were hard-working to work so hard
so I called up
the top people I said listen here's a
story we're going to put a 100 tax on
your wines and your Champagnes that come
into the United States because you're
putting a taxa no no no you can't do
that he said no no we're going to do
that it's already done the papers are
going to be signed tomorrow morning
we're putting a 100 tariffort tax
close enough we're putting a 100 tariff
they said sir on every wine all of your
wine all of your champagne oh we're
gonna miss it we're gonna miss it
because at a hundred percent you're not
going to be sending so much this like
you do now
and we'd like to think about this they
called up within an hour
and the whole tax thing was gone we had
no problems sort of on the
what a hero
but as our secretary of agriculture
Sonny Perdue said at the end of the day
farmers are better off thanks to
president Trump's policies initiatives
trade policies and his incredibly strong
support according to the economic
research service farm income is
forecasted to be at its highest level
and this didn't just happen by accident
end of quote he said this didn't happen
by accident he was a real world guys
they make fun of Biden for reading end
of quote off of the prompter and Trump
just read end of quote off of the
prompter they argue that when Biden
reads end of quote off of a prompter it
signals that he is cognitively vacant
and Trump just read end of quote off of
a prompter culture you know that Biden
reimposed the Waters of the United
States rule he reimposed it one of the
first days in office he's trying to
raise taxes on farms he wants to
reinstate the death tax and fertilizer
prices are now up by more than 300
percent for fertilizer
net farm income is projected to Fall by
16 percent this year alone
and on top of it all and if we didn't do
what we did 16 would be
75 percent
but with the insane Green New Deal Joe
Biden is trying to totally kill
Iowa ethanol
by contrast I fought for Iowa ethanol
like no president in history we've had
great support we've had really
incredible support in that from your
state but uh
not everybody supports it outside
not the easiest sell outside of Iowa but
we won't talk about that
I issued a rule declaring the E15 would
be made available all year round right
all year round nobody
said that was going to happen I also
dramatically increased the number of
fueling stations where E15 could be sold
across the country all over the country
and very importantly I let them use the
original Pumps and Equipment instead of
having to buy brand new what a guy
equipment just because I did it because
it was equal to in some cases better
than the new self so I said do it people
came to me they said we just can't
afford to redo this and remember we had
that conversation and we worked it out
so uh I'm very honored to have done it
every promise I made to Iowa as a
candidate I fulfilled as your president
nobody's ever done this that's nothing
it's never happened yeah
I made that promise to Def he did the
wall he did the new health care thing he
solved the israeli-palestinian conflict
and I I took care of it I promised to
move the embassy to Jerusalem and to get
it built and I did
I got it built for a fraction of the
cost and a fraction of the time you know
uh when they came to me sir would you
please sign this sir sure
I'm American Embassy in Jerusalem after
I announced that we're going to move it
so moving it was one thing but it would
have never gotten built it would have
been you know 20 25 years
I said how much is this two billion
dollars sir I said we're going to build
an episode like a one-story building
two-story building how do you you don't
build them for two billion dollars in
Iowa I don't think Jeffy
so I said why so much they said well I'm
really learning a lot about education
which is the subject of this speech well
we do sir but nobody's really looked at
that we'll take a look
so I called up some people and we uh
looked at it very closely and we happen
to have the best piece of land in
Jerusalem because we sort of were there
early you know where other places early
we've been there a long time huh I said
could we use it it had a building on
could we use it we'll build the embassy
there we just saved 300 million dollars
on land they were trying to rip us on a
piece of land it was not even a good
location I know a lot about location
because I'm in the real estate business
rotation is very important
right
they said yes sir but it's got a problem
what it's got a building on top of it
sir I said oh that's good maybe that's
good maybe we can use the building oh I
never thought of that sir
so I had a study done it was very strong
all of the things that you had they
wanted set back for security it's a very
big site beautiful beautiful views
really the best site and we already have
it and the building was not even
occupied
so I rebuilt the building I did this as
a personal thing and we were going to
spend 2 billion on the whole project we
ended up spending five hundred thousand
dollars this is so riveting
I went to our really he was a great
Ambassador and David I said David uh
let's see what we can do it before he
calls me back so we can do it this is
the first time I ever did this we can do
it sir for 297 thousand dollars
I've never said this before I said David
that sounds too cheap you know usually I
say let's see if you can cut it in half
cut the price in half
but you know I'm going off a two billion
dollar number so I said you know a
friend of mine a big big
I hate I hate I hate to tell you guys
this
speech hasn't actually started yet
Trump's just riffing we still have to
have him start the speech just usually I
said if you tell me that again
I said what's the big deal oh this is
the finest Stone the greatest Stone it
comes from Israel and everything else so
when I heard that I said you know two
years later I said to my guys
can we build this building in Jerusalem
Stone yes sir it's the cheapest Stone we
can buy it's right here
you believe it so the whole building is
Jerusalem so nobody can prove it and
it's gorgeous so we opened it up on time
under budget
and it's the embassy and you know
someday maybe they'll take it down and
build some stupid building that costs
two billion dollars in his own it's it's
just like a free association thing it's
it's really crazy it's worse than ever
flaring Jerusalem the capital of Israel
which is a big deal to a lot of people
in Iowa
but we got the building built Iowans are
really happy Trump moved the embassy to
Jerusalem happen if you do it it's going
to be terrible it'll be Bloodshed all
over the Middle East nothing so it was
just a way of stopping something that
people didn't want
but uh when you look at the job we did
there and we got rid of the Iran nuclear
deal now what's happened what with when
you look at what is taking place right
now it's so sad what's going on right
now they were ready to make a deal we
would have made the greatest deal ever
they would have never had a nuclear
weapon they would have been actually
happy about it
but this group came to get rich and
allowed them to dictate the terms and it
was really really a terrible thing I
promise to appoint true conservative
justices to the United States Supreme
Court and I did that three of them yeah
and over 300 federal judges the whole
court system is is different of course I
never seem to get one of them so you
know it's one of those things
I got I get killed in these courts
I if I get one you know what they do
we'd like to recuse ourselves oh great
that's wonderful
I promise that I would impose a travel
ban to keep radical Islamic terrorists
the hell out of our country and I did
that
he said I would get
reparations from China and I did that we
talked about that one that was a big one
the 28 billion for the farmers but much
more than that for a country hundreds of
billions of dollars I took in and kept
our businesses alive because they were
dumping as an example
billions and billions of dollars worth
of Steel and I was able to keep the
steel businesses alive so many people in
the steel business they come to me they
hug me they cry they hug me you saved
our
businesses by targeting even like things
like the washing machine business the
dryer business the air conditioning
business they dump all this stuff in
companies were all closing up and I
saved those businesses with taxes
tariffs we made it fair and How could a
farmer vote against me after doing all
this for the farmers if somebody called
me up and I was sort of like in a wise
guy mood I said
he said how do you think you'll do in
Iowa I said listen I got the farmers 28
videos I just want to remind everybody
that this was supposed to be a major
speech about education policy well even
Kim said it's going to be tough but we
did things that nobody thought was
possible
and we made the farming business great
made it great again if you think about
it now it's slipping away a little bit
but we'll get that back real fast but so
I said
and I saved ethanol which is a big thing
for Iowa
Farmers but a big thing for Iowa in
particular and I said sweet how the hell
would I lose Iowa how is that possible
and then I got a poll the other day that
was way up I can tell you Jeff we're way
up it's like it gets to it's it's it's
March of 2023 what is he even talking
about it's been a great stuff
great people great people
but I made those promises to the people
of Iowa in America and I kept every
single one of my promises and now we're
laying out a bold forward-looking vision
for what we will do and okay now he's
back on the prompter you can tell that
now he's on the prompter beautiful white
house and we become together the 47th
president of the United States
within hours of my inauguration I will
cancel every Biden policy that's
utilizing our problems
images
oh my God
cancel it
they call them dumps
all right thank you
I'll appoint a special team to attack
the high price of fertilizer will kept
that taken care of very quickly just
like like I did with oil
in fact I got the oil down so low I had
to save the oil companies how about that
one
remember that little period when you
were getting almost free gasoline
we had to save them we had a call
OPEC and we had to call Russia frankly
in Saudi Arabia we said we had to get
the price up
but we saved all those companies we got
the price down to
tremendously no low numbers and this
country was right we've never it was
rotten an economy like we the country
was rotten he said
and when you think about it they did
just the opposite what caused inflation
the oil price the oil energy energy
became so ridiculously expensive it
drove everything now everything is
inflated now it's More Than Just Energy
but we'll get it done we're going to get
it done we'll get it down fast and I'll
tell other countries where we spend
billions and billions of dollars on
Military protection I've said this
during my four years I'd meet with these
countries I said that's a pretty
interesting Insight inflation was up
because prices were up the prices caused
the inflation to go up it's pretty
simple oh that's nice well you're gonna
buy from us from now on or we're not
protecting you anymore everyone thought
that was terrible
and if they don't give preferential
treatment to our Farmers just like I did
for four years that's why you had all
that business the troops are packing up
and they're going to be coming home and
I tell them that and you know there's
nothing some people said that's very
tough sir
I had one gentleman a prime minister
from a certain country he was a
I saw your military equipment sir we buy
it from China
I said so wait we're protecting you
and you're buying it another one said
Russia we buy a lot from Russia how much
you buy from earlier sir sir we need
more protection
sorry I'm sorry
sir
I mean how stupid are we I have I go
through these conversations for four
years the dumbest conversations I've
ever had yeah
true but they all came alive and they
all came back and they started buying
from us
unbelievable
I'll also rapidly restore American
Energy Independence and even energy
dominance with Iowa ethanol playing a
part you know that we won't just
increase ethanol production in our
country but we'll export ethanol we're
going to export it all over the world
and just as I did for four straight
years I will protect the ethanol and I
will
go after anyone who wishes to destroy it
and let me tell you we had a lot of
people that fought me in that one it's
also by the way it happens to be a
national
security understand that in 2021 under
Biden the U.S was the top exporter of
ethanol in the world so I guess Biden's
doing something right incredible for the
place in such team Spirits I said you
know maybe I shouldn't mention this part
but we have to should I mention it
more exciting
okay so remember this Rhonda Sanctus did
anyone ever hear of the Sanctus the
sanctimonious to say
Rhonda Sanctus strongly opposed ethanol
do you know that here we go and
if he's not running I'll say he was fine
on ethanol don't worry about
he strongly opposed ethanol and fought
against it at every turn and he's going
to do that again because people that
come out early for something that's
where they go that's what it is so you
know he may do something politically but
he was very very bad on ethanol he
fought it all the way and he also fought
against Social Security he wanted to
decimate it and voted against it three
times zoning against Social Security
that's a bad one a lot of people don't
know so what DeSantis voted for was a
study group proposal that was
non-binding to raise the retirement age
to 70. I disagree with that vote but
it's not exactly voting against Social
Security we've done I think and on
Social Security well
we're at it he wanted the minimum
retirement age to be lifted to people
that are 70 years old true a substantial
increase over what it is right now he
wanted a big increase and he also voted
to severely cut Medicare I will not be
that I wasn't able to find one that's
because
but you have to remember now the crowd
likes Social Security
a poor Ryan
who is a rhino loser who currently is
destroying Fox and would constantly vote
against entitlements he would just vote
against remember that the wheelchair
over the cliffs the Democrats used it
the wheelchair over the cliff commercial
very effective that was about him but
Ryan Paul Ryan's a big reason that Mitt
Romney I'm not a big fan of Mitt Romney
lost his election
and to be honest with you Iran reminds
me a lot of Romney so I don't think
you're going to be doing so well here
but we're going to find out but those
are the facts but I'm proud to say
the final numbers just came out and the
primary elections
98.6 percent
of the people that I endorsed in the
elections in the primaries one think of
it 90th the final numbers came out young
guys
they have a 98.6 temperature everyone
else in the room could be different who
the hell no but they're they're young
they got 98.6 so it's easy to remember
98.6 of the people I endorse won in the
primaries and what you never hear from
news media
I endorsed
253 people and of the 253 people I
endorsed in the midterm elections
233 won so we've endorsed JP right JD
Mandel
[Applause]
they'll bring up one or two names
they'll bring up Herschel who's a
wonderful guy but he didn't quite make
it they'll bring Herschel Walker up
they'll bring another one up another one
I get a couple in it but think of that
and 33 wins and 20 now remember I've
talked to you all about this before it's
very easy to run up the score when you
mostly endorse incumbents or primary
winners in very red districts or states
where it mattered and there are a bunch
of these examples Trump's
um and Dorsey did not win but nobody
wants to mention it so you know what I
say
if nobody's gonna mention it mention it
yourself these kids because if nobody
else is going to toot your horn toot
your own horn and just let it out there
but that's pretty good right 200.
this guy's out of his mind
as the publication
Town Hall publication good publication
said every single time that Donald Trump
has been on the ballot Republicans
either held the majority like in 2016 or
gained seats like in 2020
the same individuals who want to blame
him for losing the senate in 20 times
was not my fault I had a lot of good
people got in because of me like North
Carolina Ted Bud like so many others we
had a lot of them including some sitting
Senators that were in big trouble but
they want to blame him for losing the
senate in 2022 by the way JD Vance did
great JD Vance was another one we've
endorsed and he's been fantastic
but they have amnesia from 2018 when
President Trump was in the White House
and Senate Republicans gained a lot of
seats that were unexpected in the
midterm elections they never mentioned
that the fake news do they but it's
funny how that conveniently left out
always in the discussion they never
liked doing and so on top of this
the publication said Trump still has
really high approval ratings with the
Republican voter base is defeating Ron
DeSantis and poll after poll by a lot
and I'm beating Joe Biden by a lot very
importantly so
so listen I uh I want you all to stick
around with me I am warning you we may
have hours of this ahead of us because
he has Mo he's done 90 percent off the
cuff
and like 10 of the written speech so far
we could be here for a very very long
time I will open the phone lines after
even if it's midnight if we get to 100
website members and twitch subscribers
but there might not be anybody here left
at that point
a lot of people in here
there's a lot of people in here
I asked people by the way we have these
rallies and this isn't a rally this is
different than a row we'll be back for a
rally soon it's a little too cold
outside
why aren't we doing one at an airport we
can have 50 000 people they said sir
it's too cold yeah that was a good call
because it's pretty cold outside when
was the last time Trump had 50 000
people at a rally
anybody know that want to get in this
great spirit two years ago
we had the most secure border and U.S
history and we will quickly do that
again we're at the most secure we had
the best numbers that we've ever had in
recorded history I built hundreds of
miles of wall
and we completed the original task as
promised and then I began to add even
more in areas where it was needed we did
hundreds of miles and then thank you I
don't know what she said but whatever
she said
[Applause]
but you know what uh we did hundreds of
miles of wall and between that and
getting Mexico to give us 28 000
soldiers free of charge he's gonna do
that story I want to hear the Mexico
soldiers story The Abdul story and the
teach transgender story love to have a
stay in Mexico policy we used to have
stay in the United States for the rest
of your life because once they were here
nobody ever got them out they never went
back they never came back they'd be
given a court hearing and they would uh
just not even they would throw the piece
of paper away it didn't mean anything
but I got to stay in Mexico policy from
Mexico if you can believe it the reason
this is the story to do this because if
you don't do it we're going to put
tariffs on everything that you have said
they said we would love to do it sir
would be a greater
they said to me we will never do that
are you they thought they thought I was
crazy I said listen I need about 28 000
soldiers of your soldiers to keep people
from coming into the United States the
guy looked at me like you gotta be
kidding me
that's the dumbest request I've ever had
I said oh no you'll do it don't worry
about it no no we will not we will not
do it we had a woman in the state
department she said sir you'll never get
these things 10 different things I asked
for including including the medical
which as you know is now expiring which
they shouldn't let that happen but she
said you'll never get it sir but I had
the second highest ranking person in
Mexico
and I said no no you'll do it no no we
will not do this why would you say that
we would do that 28 000 soldiers it's a
lot of soldiers you're going to keep
people out of the United States and
we're going to have what's called stay
in Mexico policy no sir we're not going
to do it I said well listen here's the
story if it's not done immediately on
Monday morning this was a Thursday on
Monday morning
we're going to sign I've already got it
made here's the papers right here we're
going to put taxes and tariffs on every
automobile and everything that you make
coming into the United States and that
amounts to tens of billions of dollars
so I really think you're going to do it
sir uh we'd be happy to do it sir
we'd be happy he's going like this so
that's the Mexico story now I think next
will be the Abdul story and then we'll
go to the teach transgender story that's
my guess but they did and they were
great and I really like the president of
Mexico he's a socialist but you know
can't have everything right
he's a great guy actually he's a friend
of mine he uh he said that at least that
election was rigged that election was
rigged he said I had one of them 20
years ago president I had one of them
it's not a good feeling I will tell you
but uh but he's a great guy he's a
fantastic guy and you know it's not an
easy country it's a very very tough
country Mexico very very tough very
dangerous in many ways but they have a
wonderful man leading it but they did
that and we had stay in Mexico and
nobody would come into the United States
and we had that border so until we got
approval if they were good if they
qualified and some many of them did not
that many but many and they'd come into
the United States and live happily ever
after but we kept everybody out there
wasn't MS-13 we took MS-13 out by the
tens of thousands
so we brought him back we had three the
estimate is that there's only 30 000
people in MS-13 in the entire world the
idea that Trump
deported tens of thousands of MS-13 is
tough to believe
Guatemala Honduras
El Salvador a couple of others but those
three in particular they wouldn't accept
them back and I said well
how much money do we pay them sure we
pay them 750 million dollars a year
I said okay explain to them that as of
this moment they're not getting any
money anymore
because they literally wouldn't when we
had a plane flying in with these
horrible people MS-13 and others that
are just horrible killers
rapists drug addict drug dealers
they'd be flying and they'd put planes
on the runway so our planes couldn't
land they wouldn't let our buses in they
wouldn't let anything and they didn't
want them back they were gone they were
the ones that got them out they put them
in the Caravans I came up with that damn
but it was a caravan they'd put them in
the Caravans oftentimes in the middle of
the Caravan right and you'd have this
big Caravan coming up to the country
it's just terrible so when I said we
ended all of that stuff you didn't see
that until this administered now it
blows everything away nobody's ever seen
sure what's happened sure nobody's ever
seen it but I said to him uh what
happens they said they won't take them
back so I said okay just explain that
they're not getting any money from the
United States the following morning I
got like
three calls almost at the same time
three liters of the three countries that
I mentioned
sir there must be a misunderstanding
though
what's the misunderstanding we would be
glad to have MS-13 come back we love
them very much right
and we got them out by the tens of
thousands
tens of thousands
our countries
are emptying out there you take a look
at what's going on with these countries
the other countries they're emptying out
there prisons they're
insane asylums their mental institutions
and sending all of these people and
these massive problems and unbelievable
costs they're sending them to us
it was a picture and a little story
about a mental institution in a certain
country and the doctor said you know
I've been working so hard for 20 years I
couldn't keep up with everything we're
so busy people wouldn't even have beds
they were so busy
he said now I have nobody here you know
with it it seems like antifa might be
running audio here tonight United States
of America it's our problem and you know
what
anything I would have been cleaning out
their prisons they're emptying their
prisons their prisons are empty
this is not happening it was their
insane asylums a word you're not
supposed to use anymore
words you're not supposed to use kind of
like Biden I have three words for you
we don't want to be caught in that
predicament
no more Dropbox
insane asylum
these are words you're not supposed to
be using anymore it's not politically
incorrect but mental institutions are
being emptied out by the thousands and
thousands and thousands
and think of the the money they're
saving and all of the problems they're
saving and they're dumping them into the
United States of America we're like a
Dumping Ground and we end that stuff
it'll end so fast your head will spin
it's horrible what's happened
big massive dumps you can even think
that this is acceptable and you know
when you look at their policies right no
borders no voter ID High interest rates
weak military let's stop spending woke
all over the place it's but you look at
all of these things that they do
you can't win elections with that you
can only win if you cheat and
it's okay because there's nobody gonna
say that open borders is a thing that's
popular what a great speaker when you
hear stories like that with the mental
institutions and the prisoners all
coming into the all being brought right
into the United States dumped into the
United States
we have to be a lot different on the
elections I always say I don't want any
help with the election the only thing I
want is when they're counting the votes
you got to be there you know we used to
have one day we used to have paper
ballots
we didn't have mail-in you know mail
them in anytime you want they come in by
the thousands tens of thousands
200 million ballots where are they
coming from wait on us like they're
getting dumped in their heads it's a
disgrace but we used to have paper
ballots we used to have we used to have
things where voter ID you come in and
they say we would like to see your voter
ID and then show a nice picture you know
the Democrats for their convention had a
voter idea was like this it was like a
prisoner wears actually that had more
information on that person and that was
for the Democrat National Convention
when they were like a Democrat last time
they had the biggest voter ID I've ever
seen they had pictures from every angle
angles that you don't even want to see
they had pictures
and uh but we're not allowed to have one
for voting you have to have one when you
buy groceries and other things
that's because you don't need an ID to
buy groceries what is he talking about
even 88 of the Democrats
88 of the Democrats want that when I buy
my Sumo Citrus they're in such high
demand that I get carded a Republican
government but I'm asking that what they
should do well they have this power and
go paper ballots go one day voting one
day you know some of these States
they're out there for
they're out there for 62 days think of
it it never ends
in fact on Election night they say we
can't call the election because they
have another two days or they have not
two weeks in some cases to vote no it's
horrible no voter ID same day voting you
know in the old days we had same-day
voting
and they could call a holiday if they
want they can do whatever they want
France had 36 million people vote they
used to have machines they used to have
all different things and they were
getting just really bad results bad
people ripping off the system because
anytime Jimmy Carter said it with this
Commission anytime you have mail-in
balance the system is inherently
dishonest because they go out they come
out
So Pro Series we need to have it I think
Republican Governors I think would be
very popular same-day voting paper
ballots voter ID and it's over there you
go
wow
today
those uh you guys know those really good
sweet potatoes that are purple on the
outside and the inside the purple flesh
sweet potatoes those they card me for
because they're so in demand
10 o'clock in the evening all the votes
were cast you had a winner you had a
loser the loser went home the winner
went on to govern and we should have the
same thing it's a horrible thing where
the the machines don't work well you
have a hard time we should have the
mission you see the one state we should
have the machines uh the vote within two
weeks
you know and what they do to those
machine what they're doing is just our
country is uh it's really being heard
very badly by it but everybody likes it
I've never seen an audience that doesn't
go crazy about it and I hope Republican
Governors that have that can start the
process because that's what we should
all have
as president I will sign a massive
increase in Border Patrol and a colossal
increase in the number of ice
deportation officers just so you know
these are these are incredible Patriots
you know I know some of the people
sitting up here and they're tough guys
but they're not they don't want this job
they will walk into a pack a gang from
Mexico or from El Salvador and they'll
run in and they'll start throwing and
fists and fighting and I said do you
really like doing that you know this guy
right over here my friend he doesn't
want to do it he thinks he's a tough guy
he's not tough
these guys are incredible Patriots and
they would grab him and they would take
them out you know the uh MS-13 guys they
would not so long ago they killed two
young 16 year old girls walking to
school
it really is stunning that he's able to
do these streams of consciousness
and that only we think it's weird like
the people in the audience seem to think
this is in some way normal or maybe even
interesting although maybe not
interesting because they're pretty damn
quiet but this is this is crazy this is
a very crazy way to communicate back to
the country depending on the severity
and they are great and they're great
Patriots and they they get scorned they
are scorned by the radical left they're
actually scoring the job they do is
incredible I'll ask every state and
federal agency to identify every known
or suspected gang member in America and
every one of them that is here illegally
and everybody knows it because your
local sheriffs know who they are the
sheriff the sheriff knows every bad
person in your area
but it's Politically Incorrect for him
to say that but this guy doesn't mind he
doesn't mind being Politically Incorrect
but he knows you know the good ones the
bad ones you know where they are you
can't just bring people in for that but
the local law enforcement knows
but we'll pack them up and immediately
take them out of a country and we will
deliver them to the country of origin
the country from where they came
before I arrive at the Oval Office
shortly after I win the presidency I
will have the disastrous war between
Russia and Ukraine settled 24 hours
if it's not done before though oh man
what a shame that is
what a shame what a shame what a shame
and the numbers the deaths and the
people are being so horribly injured is
far greater than what they're reporting
they blow down the city buildings all
over the building it looks like a
demolition site and it which is is
anyone aware of a city that's been blown
down say two people were injured no no
many people are killed the numbers are
far worse far worse than this being
reported it's a horror it's a horrible
thing taking place I could get that
thing settled it would have never
happened if I were president zero chance
and even the Democrats admit that
even the Democrats say now if Trump were
president and
President Putin knows could do we used
to talk about it they can't do it you're
not going to do that and he was never
going to do that until I left and then
he said well and you know what happened
he watched what happened in Afghanistan
when he saw that horror show in
Afghanistan the way we took our soldiers
out first you don't bring the soldiers
out first you bring the soldiers out
last first you get your people out then
you get your equipment out they kept 85
billion dollars worth of equipment and
now they're the
and now Afghanistan is the second
largest seller of arms in the world
they're selling they got
700 000 rifles machine guns and Guns 70
000 Vehicles many of them armor plated
you know expensive that is there's no
car lot in the in the world but in this
country that has more than a few hundred
cars 70
000 of the most sophisticated vehicles
in the world
we handed it to him we handed it to him
night goggles they have better night
goggles than us brand new never take it
out of the box you know they're good
Fighters but they never fight at them
now they can see and I dealt with Abdul
he was the leader I said Abdul I was
very proud of this I said and the Press
Hit me hard here's the Abdul story I
called it the terrorists I said because
you know Jesse James the bank robbery
they said why do you always rob banks
I've heard
why do I speak to Abdul that's where the
problem is Abdul is the leader of the
Taliban
and I said Abdul Abdul nice to talk to
you
I said but listen uh if you kill any
more of our people because he was really
they were going to town the snipers they
were going to town on our people during
the Obama Administration in particular
they would knock at him out one after
another and I see the end result I'd go
to Walter Reed which is so incredible
the doctors and the job they do but I'd
see what was what was left what was what
these people what the parents went
through with their beautiful son
sometimes daughter just decimated and
the parents are not even in they don't
even believe it when they're standing by
the bedside crying they don't even
believe what happened to their child I
said Abdul of you
kill any Soldier we are going to hit you
harder than any country has ever been
hit in the history of America we're
going to hit you hard
and we won 18 months
18 months without one soldier killed in
Afghanistan
[Applause]
and then we had the election
and the other side came in and we lost a
lot and we lost a lot that day that
horrible day where we took the soldiers
out first remember that that was a
horrible day I think it was the most
embarrassing day in the history of our
country and when Putin looked at that he
said you know I can think of more
embarrassing days if I do if I put my
mind to it
it's just incredible but I was very
proud of them think of that 18 months
without one soldier being biting
actually put it in his speech and they
were screaming at him don't say that
that's good news for Trump
but we did a good job with this
Administration
[Music]
you could end up in World War III
because they don't speak right they
don't send the message is outright
they act tough when they should act nice
they act nice when they should act tough
honestly they don't know what the hell
they're doing we're going to end up in a
world war over this stuff
we could end up in a in a major war
you could end up in a major war with
China or others there are others out
there if you're just joining us because
we have passed the stroke of 8 PM in the
East this is a speech about education
that Trump is delivering that started an
hour ago we're an hour in and nothing
has been mentioned yet about education
other than the very clear lack of it
given the Clapping from the crowd at
some very stupid stuff tell me about
nuclear the power is so enormous so this
is not like the second world war where
we have army tanks and rifles and we go
after each other this is a level that
will possibly end the world I'll be back
in five and we have people that don't
know what they're doing we have people
that truly have no clue what they're
doing
and uh you see it just like I do you see
the same language they say the wrong
thing
sometimes they're much too tough
but always on the wrong subject and
sometimes they're weak as hell like when
Biden said initially on Afghanistan well
he could go in and maybe take over some
of the country
that was not a good signal
that was not a good signal people said
did he really say that
but we have
we have inflation these are all
self-inflicted wounds much worse than
wounds we have
inflation that's rampant if you look at
what inflation over 200 years what it's
done to countries that had to suffer
through it destroys the countries
it's like cancer destroys the countries
we have now banks that are closing two
Banks two big Banks yesterday closed
that's a bad sign
that could be the beginning we have an
economy
that's in shambles you know last year
you don't realize this last year with
the worst stock market since 1929. did
you know that
we had the worst stock markets you know
you don't think of it because you
continue to do it's tighter it's tougher
you have inflation you you gasoline
costs you four or five times as much in
some cases but we had the worst stock
market since 1929 it actually goes back
longer than that it goes back to I think
1887 but I said let's use 19
29 because people understand that was
called the Great Depression but we had
the worst stock market uh people have
their 401ks does anybody have a 401k
raise your hand if you're happy with it
because not too many people anybody
happy with the results because I'll tell
you what they were happy when I was
running this country they were making a
fortune with a throwaway
I had a police officer in New York
they're great people he came up to me
said I want to thank you my wife always
said I'm a incompetent horrible investor
we have a 401k and all my life I was
suffering with her sir you don't know
what you're doing you did
sir she gave me the biggest kiss last
night I was up 59 last year this is a
few years ago and my wife loves me so
much he thinks I'm the greatest investor
ever now sir and I just want to thank
this big handsome cop from New York and
I I sort of just remembered it but many
people said that they were up 50 60 70
80 percent and now you're going down at
numbers that nobody would have thought
yeah it was the worst stock market
since
1929 think of that what that is the
Great Depression we have a country
that's a mess but more importantly it's
a world that's in serious trouble
because we have such an impact on the
world we lead the world or we
should but we're not leaving it anymore
when you see that and you see Saudi
Arabia made a deal with Iran
and they made it through China not
through the United States who would have
thought of that one who would have
thought Saudi Arabia and I said this two
years ago I said you know if they keep
going like this Saudi Arabia is going to
get together with Iran through China and
China is going to control that whole
situation it should have been done
through us we could have had that done
so easily
these things are unprecedented things
are happening that are unprecedented the
Biden Administration has driven Russia
right into the arms of China something
that is unacceptable when you're a child
studying history the one thing you learn
is you never want Russia and China to
get together and form an alliance Biden
has done that they have a big beautiful
Alliance right now
did I miss anything the arms of China
like like taking candy from a baby it
was for China it was very easy we also
have the Iran problem and I would have
had that done very quickly because they
were in bad shape financially
now they're rich again I told China if
you want to buy oil from them that's
fine but you're not going to do any more
business with the United States and uh
and they said we will not buy oil from
them they didn't and we were in a
position where we could have made a
great deal and made a deal for them to
made a deal for everybody to keep the
world safe but when I left all of a
sudden China went back and started
paying a fortune for the oil and they're
rich now Iran is very rich now and it's
a much different situation than it was
Iran was ready they were totally ready
to make a deal
that we had a bad election really bad
and we're in a position now that we have
problems that I don't think we've ever
had a more dangerous time
for this country and for the world I
don't think there's ever been again it
has to do with Weaponry but I don't
believe there has ever been a time like
we're in right now
what they've done to our country in two
years is Unthinkable it's unthinkable
standing before you today I am the only
candidate who can make this promise I
will prevent World War III because I
really believe
did I miss the education plan in the
five minutes I was gone
pretty good plan huh
because I believe you're going to have
it
get it thank you you know I saw outside
somebody was going Camp Trump was right
about everything
I hate to say it it's true
Germany with the pipeline I said what
are you doing the German delegation
during the United Nations speech my
speech they were laughing they thought
it was so funny a year later Trump was
right about that one
Germany is now you know what Germany's
doing building coal plants all over the
place as fast as they can that didn't
work out too well but I was the one that
exposed Nordstrom too it's called
Nordstrom to a pipeline
from Russia to Germany but other parts
of Europe could have Supply and I said
what are you people doing and remember I
gave the white flag of surrender I sent
it over to Angela Merkel she said but
why but why do you send this to me I
said because you will be surrendering in
a certain period of time nobody knew it
was going to be in two years
but you will be you've had many wars
with Russia they've been big Wars you
cannot
get 85 of your energy from Russia
you gotta find other sources
but they uh they thought it was so funny
now they say Trump was right about that
one too
but every step of the way we will be
opposed by the corrupt war mongers and
neocons and globalists and Communists
and all of the other menacing forces
that have been trying to take us down
with hoaxes and witch hunts and
they've been trying to do anything they
can to stop us
it's called make America great yeah guys
you know Trump was right I went and I
grabbed an orange
I was forced to have a notarized
uh idea it was crazy
there's nothing wrong
with they're breaking every law to
persecute us well Joe Biden's Brazen
corruption and criminality is totally
ignored I mean you take a look at what's
on the laptop from hell
his point is he you know after every day
does he ever say like this thing with
Hunter my son it's just not working out
real well this is you know at some point
because that laptop is a disaster
Hunter went to him actually and he said
Dad we have a problem what
I left my laptop at the repair shop
oh that's not a big problem well what's
why is that a problem son well that was
a few months ago in the repair shop now
owns it oh that's not good well what's
on it every single crime that you've
ever committed
at some point
do we know of one crime that Biden is
even accused of committing you know in
the meantime they go after us
what's happening is very simple our
enemies are desperate to stop us because
they know that we are the only ones who
can stop them
and I will totally obliterate the Deep
State I will fire the unelected
bureaucrats who have weaponized our
justice system
look at what they've done to our justice
system what they have done to our
justice system I will direct the
Department of Justice to go after Marx's
Prosecutor's offices to make them pay
for their illegal race-based
[Applause]
the investigation into Marxist
prosecutors will be a very short
investigation I can assure you Ghana's
most favorite Nations trade status you
know China says they're a they're a
growing country we need help they don't
need help they're doing just fine
but can you believe that they have a
most favored nation
I will implement the four-year plan to
phase out all Chinese Imports of
essential goods and gain total
Independence
from China that's not gonna work four
years more like 40. and I will hold
because well that's it you've got to do
it and I will hold the Chinese Communist
Party
accountable for unleashing the China
virus upon the world nobody can afford
what it is
okay
yeah I told you before that I was very
proud of the trade deal that I made with
China
and the farmers
but then we got hit with covid
and I don't even talk about that deal
anymore because covet was so horrible
and devastating I talk about the usmca
Mexico Canada but I made a deal that is
so big we talked about it but I don't
talk about this one of the few times I
mentioned because it happens to be Iowa
and it's important for Iowa but I hardly
talk about that deal anymore because all
of the Goodwill and the good feeling and
everything that was good about it got
wiped out with this horrible Chinese
China virus that came in covid they call
coveted 19. what's covet what is covid
it's the China virus it is the China box
and it came in and it wiped out that
makes sense and it wiped out all of the
Goodwill it was such a I would go around
for a few months before this happened
and I'd say we just made the greatest
deal with China it's good for China good
for us we're supplying them with food
they're paying us a fortune remember I
said I said all the farmers I just made
a deal because the farmers were with me
you know China was really hitting us
hard they wouldn't do any business
and the farmers stuck with me during
this negotiation it was tough took two
years and they stuck tight they were
unbelievable they didn't want anything I
did interview people and they'd say the
president's doing the right thing I
don't care I'm losing my shirt but the
president's doing the right thing and
they stuck with me I'll never forget
that how great the farmers were you know
everyone always wants something in
Washington I had 39 Farmers come into a
meeting in the Oval Office a beautiful
beautiful conference room I said I'm
gonna get you so much they said we don't
want anything so we just want a Level
Playing Field I'll never forget that
nobody else said that to me everyone
else they want subsidies they want
everything the windmills how about the
windmill oh no
the windmill stuff they get a lot of
subsidy but you know what they want
something the farmers wanted nothing
they just wanted I never forgot it I
tell that story a hundred times they're
unbelievable people they just wanted
they said it a Level Playing Field
and I will end Joe Biden's inflation
Nightmare and quickly rebuild the
greatest economy
in American history we had the greatest
in world history China was supposed to
take us over in 2018 was supposed for
years
2018 was The Big Year I said oh this is
a terrible thing why is that I don't
want that and we built this country so
so we had an economy that was we were
leapfrogging them they would have never
caught us
and then the virus came in and they
didn't catch us anyway but we did it
twice we built the economy twice and
we're really proud of it I will protect
Social Security and Medicare defending
our seniors from both the radical left
and the Paul Ryan Republican
establishment because that's what it is
the rhinos
the Rhinos they're worse than the
Democrats in many ways because you don't
know where they're coming from right
you don't know where the rhinos are
coming at least you know where the
Democrats are coming from and it's not a
good place but the Rhinos sometimes you
don't know as I announced earlier this
month I will pursue a Quantum Leap in
the American standard of living here we
go we will hold a competition to build
New Freedom cities on the frontier we
have this magnificent we own most of the
country
we have the most beautiful lands in the
country to give countless Americans a
new shot at home ownership and the
American dream we'll build cities
and we will support baby bonuses for a
new baby boom we want a baby boom we
want our people to have babies
like we used to have this is crazy other
countries have that problem too I will
immediately sign a new executive order
to cut Federal funding for any school
that's pushing critical race Theory
transgender insanity
transgender
thank you
and any other inappropriate racial
sexual or political content on our
children their children
I'm going to double check how long this
has been going on hold on
you know the amazing thing about that
look at the hand you get for that bigger
than uh we're going to be energy
independent the amazing thing is ten
years if somebody said that you wouldn't
even know what they're talking about
that they can mutilate our children is
without your permission this has been
going on 72 minutes already meaning he
started at 10 past seven in the east
and the place went crazy
the you know the place went crazy and I
said can you imagine what I'm doing I'm
saying parents you have rights that's
what I've said basically Sim parents you
have rights the place goes crazy because
our country has gone crazy with this
nonsense I really believe it's people
that hate our country it has to be it's
people that hate our country and just as
you're doing right here in Iowa
we will keep men out of women's sports
that's another reason wow
pretty brave huh
I don't know if anybody watches do you
see some of the records that are being
broken
that's a little the weightlifting record
guy comes in one hand being he just
broke the record have you lifted before
no not really boom it's so ridiculous
the swimmer you know I told you about
the swimmer
he got very badly injured from wind burn
as the guy went by her
so fast in the swimming pool that she
got wind burn you know so she was badly
injured the whole thing is crazy and it
really hurts women it it's doesn't it's
the opposite of dignity it's horrible
and you did it here that's great there's
some states that just I just didn't see
a certain State went the opposite way
can you believe it anyway I know one
thing if I was a basketball coach I'd be
the greatest coach in history I'd have a
woman's team I'd have all men not have
I'm not a fan of LeBron James I don't
like LeBron but I'd say hey LeBron
you ever think of becoming a woman
because you're going to be on my team
you're going to have we're going to go
undefeated for the next five years
LeBron
I'm not a fan but you know I would ask
him that question
and I will not give one penny to any
school
that has a vaccine mandate or a masked
Band-Aid
from kindergarten through college
all right
uh oh
did we just lose the feed
out of control do you hear that you know
we have some great Republican
Governors you have one right here but
they didn't close up they closed up
their state for a short period of time
and many of them didn't close at all
they didn't close at all in and they had
a lot of pressure but not for me I
allowed them to keep them open but we
have some Republican people you look at
South Carolina how well they did you
could look at South Dakota you could
look at various states that did from
Tennessee did fantastically well you did
fantastically well they weren't mandated
to do anything remember Trump used to
say how great Florida did but now he
can't do that because he's he'd be
praising to Sanctus he did a fantastic
job many of our young people are still
dealing with the Fallout of the
prolonged school closures and the
cancellations and the sports and
activities and they become anti-social
lots of bad things happen will be the
administration that commits to get these
kids back on track and quickly kids are
going to go back to school and
participating fully
and now they're really in the process
this stream is super glitchy let's see
if this other one has improved and we
could stick with it the problem was the
audio was unsynced from Trump's mouth
track and quickly
kids are going to go back to school and
let's try this participating fully
and now they're really in the process of
finally getting it done but this must be
our priority has to be and I will tell
you that I want to congratulate Iowa on
recently becoming the second state of
the nation to deliver Universal school
choice that's so great
School choices where it's a
that's great
very important to you isn't it very
important I know every time I'm with him
she really finds the education you know
some people are for it and some people
are less for it some people want to talk
about trade and some people want to talk
about other things but always been very
very strong on education I've seen what
you've done here it's incredible as
president I'll fight to expand that
right to every single state in America
and we were doing that too and I'll
support
the direct election of school principals
by the parents they should be elected by
the parents
oh God if any principal is not getting
the job done of which you have many I've
never heard many especially in the inner
cities the parents should be able to
vote to fire them and to select somebody
who will Who will get the job
in addition I am going to pursue and we
studied it very closely and I was
getting ready to do it pull the trigger
the long-term goal but now it's a
short-term goal of breaking up the
Federal Department of Education you know
it is a good question when they talk
about school choice the where the vast
majority of these right-wingers who want
that are it's like it's less Urban and
more rural does this mean they want to
like choose to go to a school that's two
hours away and drive I mean it just did
I don't even really get the idea that
they envision
but this is what must be done to save
our
country from destruction all of these
things and remember this on having to do
with education
out of the top 40 countries we're always
at like the bottom of the list in terms
of success per student and yet I believe
it's about three times and even
sometimes four times more than the
second third and fourth country so we
spend three to four times more on
educating a pupil and yet we're at the
bottom of the list
they're at the top of the list and they
spend much less money so you know the
system doesn't work so breaking up the
Department of Education is a it's funny
they don't use that exact same logic
when it comes to Health Care
and 2024 is the final battle that's it
if you put me back in the White House
the reign of the corrupt Washington
establishment will be over I got the
normal
[Music]
when I went there I didn't know a lot of
people I had to rely on in some cases
rhinos and others to give me some
recommendations but I know I'm all now I
know the good ones I know the bad ones I
know the weak ones I know the strong
ones we know them all and America will
be a free Nation once again and with
your support
and these caucuses we will
and we're always keeping you there we're
going to
complete our mission we are going to see
that job through we did such a job there
was a report today we were as good as
any president there's never been an
Administration that's done more than we
have done we rebuilt our military
largest tax cuts in history largest
Trump is now 80 minutes into this speech
80 minutes people are dying and they
couldn't use drugs that were perfectly
good perfectly good but it takes takes
two three four years to get them
approved
by the FDA sometimes would take 13 14
years we cut that in half down to five
cut it in more than half
and when people are terminally ill are
very ill
I passed something got it passed they
were trying to do it for 54 years I got
it passed
in Congress right to try where you no
longer have to go to Asia or
Europe or wherever you may go to try and
find a miracle cure you can stay home
and use because we have the greatest
doctors in the world the greatest labs
in the world
and if you're critically ill if you're
terminally ill or even a little bit less
than that you don't have to do there's
many people are going to far away lands
and they would die but they'd go to far
away lands many people would go home if
they didn't have money they couldn't go
to far away lands they'd go home and
they'd die they'd sit in their room and
they'd die now you sign a paper
and you have right to try and you can
use things that work
but they're not approved yet because you
have to go through a process and people
said sir you can't do that because
you'll maybe make the person very sick I
said the person is terminally ill
person is two weeks to live
and we've saved thousands and thousands
of lives this is another thing nobody
ever thought we could get that approved
we saved thousands of lives people that
are living right now with drugs that are
Advanced with all of the things they can
do now that things you wouldn't even
imagine possible
but we did so much
we rebuilt our military think of that we
had planes we had fighter jets say that
already and then the father and then the
the sun is flying it or was flying it we
have all do all the beautiful stuff the
85 billion that we gave away is too bad
but that's actually small compared to
what we did we rebuilt our entire
entire military and it was it's been
amazing
given a lot of it away though I'll tell
you we'll give it a lot of it away and
we're going to finish what we started
the people of Iowa have always been
there for me they've always been you've
always been there for me somehow we had
a
a great relationship right for the
beginning and I think I can honestly say
that I have always been there with you
and I always will be there with you
what
together we will end the era of
weaponized government
forever
we will end woke we will crush the Deep
State we will save our economy we will
defend our Farmers we will evict Joe
Biden from the White House
and we will make America great again
thank you ah is that the end
very low energy
there's a lot of people up there
I remember if Trump gets the questions
we still have the opportunity to open
phone lines when he's done if we get to
100 website members we will do it and
the place is going crazy and then they
start screaming Encore Encore come back
and he'll come back he'll do another
good one drive him then he comes back
and he hits a little bit of a dud
people leave unhappy it's very stupid to
do a couple of questions
but let's give it a shot should we do
that should we or not yes okay here we
go do we have a mic someplace we'll take
a few questions ask whatever you want
but you know it's uh
you know the story right encores are
always dangerous
especially for singers you want to know
the truth go ahead who's got the mic
Uncle Sam you do good let's go
what do you have Uncle Sam I like that
man I like the way he's this is Uncle
Sam go ahead
go ahead you have a mic yeah go ahead
you could give it to anybody that is a
great anybody has a question go ahead
ma'am please
go ahead as a member of moms for Liberty
yes uh parental rights and education are
top priorities yes seems like schools
have become indoctrination camps where
they're focused on sexualizing our
children and it's just not right how do
we get back to the basics it's wrong
teaching you know Reading Writing and
arithmetics right that's right and
civics
thank you Mr President you know
everything I said tonight they could say
he's conservative he's got a wonderful
conservative voice actually it's a voice
of common sense with education almost in
many ways easier than other things we
have to get back to Common Sense and
that is Reading Writing arithmetic what
they're teaching in schools today is
insane and most people understand that
even the people that want it they
understand it so we're going to do
something and a lot has to do with your
Governors and your people that are
leading your safes no answer you know
they're going to be given free reign to
do what they want to do you happen to
have a great Governor that's very much
into it and she's taken the state so I'd
love one person to get up and go sir
what does it mean to teach transgender
thank you very much thank you so not an
answer yes please go ahead
go ahead
can't hear anything
that's interesting yeah Trey Gowdy's
very good I think he's very good uh we
have
we have uh we'll have all the great
choices for vice president we're going
to pick a great one oh we're gonna have
a lot of great choices you know this
whole process is interesting there are
those that say they're all
campaigning right now to be vice
president we've heard that a little bit
but I will tell you we'll pick a great
one thank you very much interesting okay
question over here go ahead please
yeah
Mr President
our farmers are under attack from
increased Fuel and fertilizers prices at
the same time we're demonized by
Washington and climate life leftists how
do we protect our farmers
and reduce oh my God Iowa Farmers so you
were totally protected two and a half
years ago hard to believe it's two and a
half we have all lives you're gonna have
to go it seems so short now when you had
to think in terms of much longer but you
were totally protected like never before
I think you would say like never before
we will bring that back so fast your
head will spin a big thing is to get the
fuel price down once that fuel price
comes down a lot of other things are
going to happen including the fertilizer
which I hear is a disaster for Farmers
right now so we're going to take care of
all of it yeah he heard from that woman
right now quickly okay thank you thank
you man
none of these are answers that's crazy
go ahead over here Mr President I'm full
of gratitude for everything you have
done
for us and are doing for us
for We the People
I just like to ask thank you thank you
sir
and what so far I love this question
uh I'm I'm getting ready for the kill
so go ahead what can you do to bring
back manufacturing jobs
well I was doing that and one of the
things we're doing is making it very
difficult to have Auto plants in
Michigan or leave our country we had
almost nobody leaving during my
Administration and one of the things you
do is you have to tax some of these
products that come back I'll tell you I
don't think the questions are scripted I
think the people asking them are morons
I should dry her the many Industries
because they were dumping product that
wasn't as good but it was pretty good
and they were dumping product into the
United States I saved so many different
they call them dumps manufacturers if
you look at whirlpool in Ohio they they
had such a problem Korea South Korea was
dumping and China
thousands and thousands millions of
units in at a price that is just they
wouldn't they weren't going to work and
I ended that I put a 50 tariff on and I
was with them that part of Ohio is
thriving today it's thriving and those
companies are doing great so we have to
look at individuals but we will be able
to handle that situation very easy don't
forget we have a thing we have a power
called the economy we have a very
powerful engine and the problem is we
have people that really don't know how
to use it they don't know how to use it
so his answer is I did already fix
everything you're asking about and I
will fix it again thank you very much
thank you okay question over here
thank you president Trump under Biden
the installed president we're seeing
mobs of illegals coming across our
border just this last week we saw a
violent mob try to force their way
across the border narrow Castle what can
we do to finally secure our Southern
border and finish the wall it'll be
secured on day one and then we have to
make a decision what do we do with the
15 million people
that have invaded our country the
question was how will you secure it the
right thing that I tell you we will
really disgusting everything about this
sheriffs and law enforcement who we love
the sheriffs know every one of them that
shouldn't be here what I would give for
one really good confrontational question
we'll take
we'll take this go ahead
[Applause]
came after you and your family like
crazy but not one of them seems
interested in investigating the Biden
crime family or Hunter's laptop
they also censored anyone who asked
questions in 2020
how do we get to the bottom of this okay
this does seem scripted now I'm coming
around this seems completely scripted I
announced I was running for president
and just today I read where it reached
an all-time low because people are wise
to what's been happening what they have
done they really are a political arm of
the
Democrat Party it's it's a terrible
thing you saw you saw last couple of
weeks where the FBI and Twitter it's
called Twitter files where they work
together and they work together with
Facebook you couldn't say anything good
about Trump and you couldn't say
anything bad about Biden they had the
laptop they knew all about the laptop
very much I knew all these crimes are on
the laptop and they weren't allowed to
do anything they weren't allowed to talk
and frankly they have that liberal
inclination anyway but even if they
wanted to they couldn't do it I think
we're making a lot of progress I think
that the that Congress is doing a very
good job now we have some people Nancy
Pelosi is packing
getting her out is a big that's a big
step
and I think Kevin and all of the people
in Congress I tell you what you know
that whole
people thought it was a fiasco I think
it was a beautiful thing as it turned
out that five or six nights of voting
and voting and voting and voting I
actually think that was like a cleansing
action it was a great thing that
happened and there's it was a cleansing
community in Congress we do have to do
something about Mitch McConnell he's
he's a disaster
he's a disaster he gets his 10 guys and
they give Biden whatever they want
there's something going on that doesn't
make sense they give them whatever they
want he gets his 10 12 guys
and they vote and then I said in order
to give the passage
they vote and they give him what he
wants I just cannot understand nobody
can understand it we got to get him the
hell out he's a problem big problem
in the meantime I hope he's feeling well
but he's a big problem okay go ahead
we'll take one or two more go ahead
hello Miss hello Mr President got to be
a good one you know if it's a good one
I'm out of here right if it's a bad one
I'll I've got to take a couple of more
to get over the stench of the bed I just
want to say it's an honor to hear you
speak thank you but my question for you
is what can you do to combat transgender
athletes taking over women's sports well
you've done it here because your
Governor's past legislation you can't no
it's a major issues it's like how does
uh people are seriously in favor of
having it done and I don't understand it
and I tell the story of that champion
swimmer and she's there and she's
looking up and down the line she sees
friends that she's been swimming with
she's a champion and then she sees this
person next to her and he's a monster he
looks like Wilt Chamberlain but a little
bit different oh my God she sees the guy
has a wingspan she's like looking up and
downs and she looks up wow
and you know he broke all these records
and it's just a it doesn't make sense it
doesn't make sense you would almost say
and I said it once before tonight but
you would almost say it's people that
want to hurt our country because it
doesn't make sense and that one's a very
easy one yes a trans athlete wants to
hurt the country by competing doing it
some states are going the opposite
direction which is shocking it's
shocking but we'll get it done
throughout the country it's going to
happen it's happening it's just common
sense it's a great question too yeah
great great question see you Mr
President Michael my grocer bills are
going
as someone on a fixed income that really
hurts and it feels like Joe Biden
doesn't even care about us in so-called
flyover country
how are we going to fix these prices
under control oh my God you see
groceries right yes the groceries are
terrible I mean you look at eggs and you
look at bacon and you look at just what
we used to consider Staples and you see
the kind of numbers a lot of it's going
to have to do with energy once the
energy comes down a lot of other things
are going to follow energy is so big
it's so powerful it's so impactful that
once the energy comes down you're going
to see a lot of good things happen and
we have more energy than any other
country in the world more than Saudi
Arabia more than Russia I call it liquid
gold and it's right under our feet
I mean when you look at the craziness
we're allowed to go to Venezuela to take
their energy and it's horrible it's tar
it's bad it pollutes you know where they
uh refine it in Houston so they talk
about the guy asked about groceries tell
it to Houston because that's the only
place that has the refineries for this
kind of very bad potential oil and they
refine it in Houston so if your
groceries are super expensive because
they make you show your ID to buy cereal
and it's just incredible we have
the greatest energy in the world you
know I approved something I was very
proud of it Anwar Alaska and Anwar is
the biggest probably probably the
biggest site anywhere in the world and
probably bigger than Saudi Arabia just
that one so Alaska
and Reagan tried to do it he couldn't
get it done Bush tried to do it he
couldn't get it done of course and other
people couldn't get it done nobody could
get it done I got it done and the first
day in office
they terminated Anwar and this would
have been incredible to have for our
country I mean literally we were going
to become energy dominant we would have
made because it's a big big industry we
would have made so much money that we
would have started paying off debt
lowering taxes still further we would
have done something that nobody's ever
seen oh who believes we have so much you
know I filled up the Strategic National
reserves I knew not much about it I said
one of the reserves that we want to fill
up and that's been taken for years and
years down to a low level
and I made a great deal I got very
little credit for it but when our when
our oil price hit like these crazy low
numbers that's when I asked the question
because we had so much
I said what about filling in the caverns
these are these massive as in in
Louisiana and various other salt like
the salt mines the big massive salt
lines
and I bought 75 million barrels for
peanuts and filled it very close up to
the top well you're going to be topping
it out
and then Biden
just before the election in order to
keep prices a little low
he released all of that and now we've
set a record low they've taken all of it
and then some and we have the lowest
that they've ever seen it
right now it's the lowest that they've
ever seen meaning question was about
groceries right
fill up almost to the top would have
been topped out at really low prices and
by the way now they have to pay three to
four times more than what I was paying
and the Democrats fought me all the way
they got a stopped actually for a while
they fought me all the way at a price
the funny thing is even if people came
here with the idea of listening and
understanding it's impossible it's a
crazy thing and a lot of times we'll say
common sense but the other side either
doesn't have common sense or they really
hate us and let's take one more I'm
looking at that big powerful guy there I
don't know who's a better looking guy
weapons let me see I don't know he looks
good they look they look good you you
look you look fantastic and we love you
ah thank you very much I appreciate it I
appreciate it
I appreciate it thank you you're the
greatest executive I've ever observed in
my lifetime and I think you've made it
possible for Governors including Kim
Reynolds whom I love and respect for
many years to become the really high
level Executives by your example now you
have passed legislation or got
legislation passed for like a wall it
got paid for it was passed you signed it
and then there was the uh none of that
happened all of these things have to do
with interstate commerce right there are
section one or article one section 8 in
the Constitution Biden had no Authority
in law to reverse those things and what
would you do to see to that never
happens again give me a breakthrough new
actions and with the legislation give me
a break he said great I love your
question I like your statement even more
than your question to be honest with you
this could be the last question of the
night because I love it appreciate it
appreciate the job you do also do you
know each other I'm sure if you know
each other do you know who that is that
man huh
[Music]
yeah I love this guy I love them both
ready so I think what happened what
happened Trump has no idea what the
question is very simple the Keystone
pipeline was a tragic mistake that they
made that was so much coming from other
parts and it was going right into the
source everything would have been it
would have been so great and by the way
environmentally much safer the wall I
built hundreds of miles of wall but I
ended up getting uh I want to use a nice
word because we have such young people
here
but the word that would normally be used
would be screwed but I wouldn't use that
word because I don't want to get in
trouble with the parents of these two
beautiful young boys screwed no what
they did is they took advantage of the
American public and we built hundreds of
miles but there was other areas that we
could have built I ended up having to
take it out of the military because I
considered it an invasion and the Army
Corps of Engineers did a fantastic job
we built hundreds of miles of it but I
didn't get it the old-fashioned way like
getting it approved because the
Democrats afford US every inch we had 11
lawsuits remember that the question was
about uh what was it article one section
8 or something like that I had to fight
the wall but the bottom line is it sort
of shows it's a good example if you want
to get something done if you love our
country and you really want if it's so
important you're going to get it done
you're going to find a way to get it
done this was sort of ingenious we
passed this big military budget but we
couldn't get a wall built for a tiny
action of that and I said this is an
invasion of our country and it is by the
way this is an invasion of our country
what's coming across our border it's no
different than soldiers and they bring
in a lot of different problems than
soldiers would bring they're not
bringing merely bullets and they're
bringing plenty of them but they're
causing tremendous problem for our
country and it's a problem that we may
have a very he doesn't answer a single
question and I don't even think he
understands the questions to be totally
honest with law enforcement to do it
properly not going to be easy
but they're hurting our country they're
killing the blood the life stream of our
country and we're going to do something
about it but why they killed the
Keystone I have no idea and the union
representing all of those thousands of
workers 48 000 workers
they endorsed the union endorsed Biden
that's a fair comment in the in Trump's
defense the people asking the questions
also don't seem to understand them
that's very true
second or third day in our as he
terminated the Keystone Pipeline so you
know so the people in that Union are not
too happy not too happy but look bottom
line is we have to use common sense
right we have to do a little bit like
Kim or a lot like him and some other
Governors you know Kim you would be the
first to admit we have some great
Governors Republican Governors perhaps
some Democrats do but they don't seem to
have our policies at all you look at any
democrat-run state and it's just not the
same it doesn't work if you look at
these cities our great cities are New
York City is a crime Den remember that
the crime rate is higher in Oklahoma
City in the state of Oklahoma run by
Republican Governor Kevin's tit than New
York City or New York state but Trump
won't talk about that one of the other
things I'll do because you know you're
supposed to not be involved in that you
just have to be asked by the governor or
the mayor to come in
I'm not waiting one of the things I did
was let them run it and we're going to
show how bad a job they do well we did
that we don't have to wait any longer we
got to get crime out of our cities thank
you very much for a good question ladies
and gentlemen thank you very much Kim
thank you very much appreciate it thank
you thank you everybody thank you
wow that was great
[Music]
what a speech huh
what do you think these people say to
themselves when they leave man that was
really great he was just Electric
he said so many great things and laid
out so many important policies I really
feel like I understand what he plans to
do and just
it's just so great so great
man it's it's all crazy it is really
real like it's genuinely crazy that this
is what's going on listen folks I love
uh that so many of you join me please
remember if you're watching on YouTube
before you leave
hit that subscribe button it is free and
we are slowly inching towards two
million subscribers it costs
oh my God
it quite literally costs nothing hit
that subscribe button for us make sure
to follow if you're watching on Twitch
make sure to do the entire thing do all
of it do everything and we've got a
great uh program coming up tomorrow
um we've got uh oh it took people are
saying that the Trump cult explains
everything yeah basically
basically
um
we are going to have to do a little
revamp I think of uh a bunch of
different stuff from the standpoint of
moderation and we're going to look into
it super strongly but I'm going to be
back very soon we're going to see
everybody the streams are working the
streams are back it is all happening and
we'll see you all very very very very
soon
mangoes my bad my bag of mango
ES
back 11 dollars and 99 that seems like a
pretty good deal a bag of mangoes mango
art mangoes
eight or eleven bucks
goes back down
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]